if you look at cars from the 1970s and
cars from the 1990s there's really one
big difference in their designs the ones
from the 70s are boxy and the ones from
the 90s are curvy for some car models
you can even tell the exact year when
that change happened just look at this
commercial for the Buick LeSabre showing
the 1991 model and then the 1992 model
see the curves let's watch that again 91
is boxy sharp edges 92 smooth and around
and since then cars have become curvier
and curvier so how did this happen when
manufacturers started making curvy cars
in the 90s it wasn't a totally new
concept back in the 1930s extreme liners
like this Chrysler airflow used a sleek
design to reduce wind resistance but as
the 50s and 60s rolled around American
streamliners stopped selling well they
were outsold by bigger boxier cars and
gas prices were on a fairly steady
decline at this point so streamlining
for fuel efficiency was less of a
concern well into the 1970s just about
every car made in America had sharp
edges and very few curves they were
basically designed as a series of three
boxes the hood the cabin and the trunk
and that model it worked really well in
the US market but in Europe fuel was
always more expensive in the 60s a
gallon of gas in France cost a whopping
seventy three point one cents while it
was just thirty one cents in the u.s. so
European designers started experimenting
with more aerodynamic designs to help
cars move more easily so they waste less
gas automakers like Porsche and BMW and
Audi and Mercedes Benz they all started
rolling out car models that had curved
exteriors then eventually American
automakers started to copy the European
aerodynamic look to try to attract
upscale customers the mass-market was a
different picture and Europe a designer
named Eva Bunsen was the first person to
push for a curved design for the average
driver and he did that with the 1982
Ford Sierra it was curvier than any car
in its class at the time but critics
just laughed at it and it didn't sell
very well at first it was nicknamed the
jelly mold because of how much it looked
like the kind of circular shape you'd
make jello with
one of the designers from that European
Ford design team this guy Jack tell
knack took over the u.s. design team in
1980 American gas prices at this point
were skyrocketing due to conflict in the
Middle East so tell Nick brought
Windtunnel testing into the design
process he first did that with a 1983
Ford Thunderbird but the real
breakthrough came a few years later the
result was the groundbreaking 1986 Ford
Taurus it might not look that
groundbreaking now but this style was
revolutionary at the time it was a
mass-market car with curvy edges and
people liked it they used it in Robocop
as the car of the future
future and the sales basically saved
Ford which had really been struggling at
the time and it inspired a whole wave of
copycat curvy cars and streamlining
became even more popular because
manufacturers were facing new fuel
economy regulations in the u.s. starting
in 1978 the average fuel efficiency of
each manufacturers passenger cars had to
meet higher and higher levels according
to one for designer aerodynamic design
was a much more affordable way to boost
efficiency than doing engineering work
under the hood the rise of computer
modeling in the 80s also made it easier
for car makers to design and manufacture
curved lines all these years later the
influence on today's cars is pretty
clear even the models that we criticized
for being ridiculously boxy these days
like the Scion xB are actually really
round and if our modern day sci-fi
movies of anything to say about it that
won't be changing anytime soon
[Music]
you